[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
welcome to the ninth episode of the joke
world podcast today's guest thank you
for joining us we have mike cannon on
what's up man what's up good to meet you
dude good to meet you as well so it's uh
we're gonna do it in person when i was
out in tampa but uh yeah that fell
through but i'm glad we got to do it
yeah me too thanks for uh for making
that adjustment how how did you enjoy
the tampa shows i liked it man it was
great of course i was there during the
weekend where the lightning we're
playing the rangers and the nba
it's like every every
you know fan of mine that does not care
for sports at all and some begrudging
came through so it was it was nice but i
felt bad that i was tearing them away
from their local celebration yeah are
you a big sports guy i know that you
like hoops but yeah you're in the back
yeah i'm big basketball big football um
a little bit baseball here and there
like i like the live events way more
than following it on tv or anything sure
but um you know golf here and there i
follow pretty much everything i just
don't like the only thing i really truly
invest time in is is basketball okay so
what did you think about last night
because i mean
did you think it was well let me hear
what you think but i thought it was
really strange how steph was like laying
on the floor while the game was still
like i get dude it wasn't his first
championship it wasn't like
maybe it might have been the most
impressive but at this point like you're
considered one of the greats i don't
think it was that shocking you were up
22 points they had their scrubs in yeah
for me it was like i don't get it was i
thought it was weird at the end
i think i think this is the year where
we've found out that
rich people still read comments
you know what i mean like from will
smith to elon musk to the [ __ ]
warriors and every other nba player
steph is doing the i thing like zero
championship like they're all quoting
other people that wronged them or play
like direct quotes to that grizzlies
player yeah yeah which i i don't mind
that because that's another player so
it's like yeah [ __ ] out of here but yeah
but yeah in general like it's it's
interesting man these guys are are
insanely talented and absolute petty
sensitive yeah children yeah like and
i guess you gotta be on some level i
mean and how could you not because i
feel like growing up
like i was like these guys are just like
superheroes and then as i've become like
the same age as them like i'm the same
age as jason tatum and i'm just like oh
these are just like dudes are just
freaks at one thing yeah and then
they're just normal people for the most
part i mean like lebron's probably not a
normal person at this point that's too
much celebrity but like for the most
part a lot of these dudes are just like
probably reading the comments and taking
them to heart they're just normal people
that are great at throwing the ball like
well and it's how they grew up like they
grew up with social media so it's it's
hard it's as hard for them to pry away
from it as it is for us yeah apparently
i did have this like
dream life in mind that once i once i
reached a certain level of financial
stability i would like
never even consider the internet's
opinion again yeah but apparently like
watching these guys that just never
comes no
yeah i mean maybe that's why he was so
emotional because like you could say
it's his first mvp
and i wouldn't even i mean and i'm a
cavs fan so like this was kind of
i don't really like them the most and i
i don't think you can even count the
durant championships i that that is just
like
the most i don't even know why they
played those two seasons
for the whole nba like
they said they should have just given
them to him before the season that team
was just insane so i guess i get a
little bit why this one would be
different but you're right it's clear
that they are like it was more than just
beating the celtics
yeah yeah it was like you know the first
step i get it and clay i certainly get
it because he was away for like three
years or whatever it was you know he
hadn't played basketball for a long time
so the fact that his first season back
they won a chip that's pretty incredible
i do not i think like draymond running
around being like what can they say now
what can they say now it's like i don't
know man your game high for the series
was like 11. yeah that's what they can
say shut up your prop was three and a
half points like serious like a for real
like
i genuinely do like him and i think he's
got like
i think he'll have a sick media career
for sure oh yeah the next next tnt
yeah but he like
you know again it goes back to this
sensitivity which i think the reason it
bothers me so much is because i'm also a
sensitive baby and i look to these guys
to be better than me yeah and they're
not yeah i agree and sometimes it feels
weird to see someone like draymond like
crying and being all sensitive when it's
like dude you're like six nine like
you're you're a monster you're [ __ ]
like you don't need to be like
listening to the chirps of these dudes
like in dude i don't know he's made the
best hall of fame career off being on
the team with like the most insane
shooters of all time and then act i hate
him but i can
[Laughter]
i just say yeah he's like you know he's
similar in the in the way that he plays
to like dennis rodman maybe a little
more like offensively minded yeah but
yeah for the most part it's just like
hey man you really like you hit the
lottery you figured out what you needed
to do and you did those things but then
also you have to give credit to the nba
and how they've just coddled him as an
athlete and a human being because most
of the [ __ ] that he does
would be a technical flagrant ejection
yeah for truly anybody else in the
league for real dude the one clip of him
like like people are going over his
shoulder he's like
dude he's the moving screen king which
is works so well when you have two of
the best shooters of all like and i
don't know i am i'm so anti it's like oh
everyone wants to be like oh he's like
the smartest player in the nba maybe
it's like really would the smartest
player in the nba be kicking people in
the balls and getting ejected when he
knows his team needs them like i don't
think he's the smartest player in the
nba i think he's got a huge temper and
can throw it to anyone on his team and
they will just make it from anywhere
like yeah i'd like to see how that iq
would do on the knicks
i'd put up two assists in golden state
in a game i swear oh easy man yeah easy
if you could just get me to swing the
ball i'd have eight nine assists if you
played me for 20 minutes yeah no problem
how how i asked my roommate this other
day i'm a big i love sports
hypotheticals how i mean who doesn't how
how many if you had to start the first
10 minutes of that game last night what
was golden state i think
i think they were plus three and a half
or something going into the game
what would the what would the line
change and you can actually play but you
have to go
it would be
i mean it's substantial we would have to
be like a
20 point like you know like yeah it
would have to be at least 20. i don't
know how how high the lines go but i
would be
you know i everybody but i myself too
like watch trey young and i'm like this
guy doesn't play d he's staying small
yeah he's just an olay like it's there's
no effort being put in i am a
doily like a human doily in comparison
to him i would just be completely busted
through anybody with any type of
physicality speed yeah jerky whatever
i'd tear my my achilles within 11
seconds of being on it yeah i think
marcus smart would make me cry if he was
guarding me for real maurice's heart is
out of his mind dude so that's what's
amazing about the athlete's sensitivity
right is that like all of them are very
clearly you know keyed into their own
[ __ ] they have their own issues they
they chirp it back out into the world
but on the court these guys say like
unforgivable [ __ ] to each other like
crazy i mean think about kevin garnett
saying carmelo that is his wife tasted
like honey nut cheerios like that moment
in [ __ ] talk that stuff that kind of
stuff happens all the time and it's like
that was my huge downfall as an athlete
is i would let
my emotion and temper key into moments
like that and completely take me out of
the game so i do not have the mental
fortitude to deal with even like
a d-level [ __ ] talker yeah
yeah then imagine that from the whole
arena too i mean you can't hear it
specifically what do you remember any um
any specific like times where someone
really got you good with a chirp
i mean i remember when an entire uh
crowd got me good with a chirp so i
played junior college basketball with
which you know can either be high level
or really low level it kind of depends
where you play we ended up being a
pretty serious team that played against
division one you know guys that couldn't
they had like you know 40s on their sats
yeah
yeah so they couldn't go play anywhere
but they were like
athletic freaks like yeah you know like
ben wallace i think was a yes yeah
exactly just guys that like couldn't get
the grades but certainly you know par
with that with that kind of talent pool
and we played sullivan county community
college in upstate new york it's like an
hour and a half outside of the city and
the the uh the entire room i was like
one of two white people in the entire
500 plus you know sat for whatever
reason yeah community college games were
the [ __ ] in this town we've never got
crowds like that at our home gym but for
whatever reason this was like the social
event of the evening their entire campus
packed into this gym and again i'm used
to this i played hoops my entire life so
that never bothered me before at all but
this entire crowd as if they got
together beforehand uh every time i
touched the ball chanted cracker
so literally 500 strong every time i
touch the ball we're just like crap
cracker and this is like [ __ ]
this is not even the end dude so this is
like this is back when i had you know a
ton of self-confidence before life has
truly kicked me in the teeth
you know and i thought anything could go
wrong you're still balling yeah yeah
exactly i had that mentality so
my first shot i put up no problem i put
up my first shot probably two or three
minutes into the game several cracker
chants later and i just drill a perfect
swing pass from the top of the key three
and i look into the crowd because
they're only sat on one side and it's
just 500 wall of people and i look and i
kind of side like side yeah yeah
and i grab my nuts
at the whole crowd like a slight kind of
grab of my nuts baker mayfield yeah and
they're just like silent
and then after i mean you know it
probably was like two beats three beats
but it felt like a minute
it's totally silent some guy goes
probably the first shot you ever hit
[ __ ] and the entire place
erupted
erupted in cheers and i was just like my
soul like shang sung from mortal kombat
touched down and put his hand on my
shoulder there's no coming back from
that
nothing
you gotta you gotta
that's hilarious dude when they that's
so funny when there's a silence and you
can have a whole captive audience like
in public like that
yeah person maximized their time that is
awesome dude good for that guy that guy
so it seems like you're grabbing your
knots your grab you know talking back a
little bit were you all you i also like
to get in the [ __ ] talk
yeah but again like i've only recognized
this as an adult you know what i mean
like all while i was in it
i thought that's what drove me the
emotion the the the anger the blah blah
blah but i as an adult i've just
recognized that i i'm like paralyzed by
that [ __ ] yeah it never helps me at all
i'm almost like like a wet cat every
time i get angry angry because i'm like
i'm so [ __ ] scared and angry and
whatever that i have very little control
over what i do that makes sense so you
know i i used to think that it helped
but now i just know that like had i not
gotten sucked into that i probably would
have been a little bit better yeah
that's so that's so true because like
like playing au and stuff growing up
like yeah i was on mostly you know the
the the team of other suburban kids and
like we got into this tournament and
then sometimes you dr you'd play a team
from like detroit or somewhere locally
and it's like i'm so scared to be on the
court right now like this is
like they're like trapping full court
and you're like oh yeah but in your head
you're growing up in like seventh grade
you're like i have to be i have to be
like kobe i have to have the mamba
mentelli i i like [ __ ] exactly what you
just said you're like no like this is
part of it this is what all the this is
what jordan would be doing and now
growing up it's like i'm way less of
kobe i'm way more of like kevin love
dude i'm like
of the sensitive guy yeah i just want to
i just want to play basketball
yeah if someone's talking to me i'm just
like okay i just want this to be over
dude yeah okay yeah i mean you know yeah
all that stuff i was just like i got
sucked into that stuff and i did like it
i there was part of me that really truly
liked it especially at the playgrounds
like because my favorite thing in the
entire world was i was a slap i was a
flashy inefficient player so i i i yeah
jason williams he was my guy you know
just just players like that i love
perfect for pickup basketball exactly i
was a i was a world-class pickup
whatever
organized player and so at parks i'd
bust ass and then would like chirp and
do all that [ __ ] and i loved it and then
you take it to a real game with like
real stakes and real coaching and real
audience and it's like it's a completely
different ballgame wow i don't i i could
not agree more i didn't expect to be
talking about our our basketball game
this much but i couldn't even agree more
because like i play i still play every
tuesday pick up outside here and it's
like
in those games when there's no fouls and
i can just like go
drive as hard like put my head down and
it'd be an offensive file every single
time i go to the bucket it would be an
offensive file or my coach would be like
what are you do like in fake basketball
it's so fun to like just go hard and
like be chirping and talking [ __ ] but
then like with an actual coach and an
offense and like
real refs and jerseys on it's like this
is different dude i don't yeah and a
game plan yeah yeah like a game plan
that does not account for your ego and
the clock too it's not like the first
team to get to 12 points it's like this
is this keeps going yeah exactly it's so
different that's fun so
so when did you realize like
i don't think i'm going to be in the nba
uh so late
so
embarrassingly late dude that's why like
and i know people people that are
familiar with me are so annoyed by how
much i talk about sports and and my ex
athlete days yeah and it's like i'm not
even talking about them from i was the
man perspective yeah i'm talking about
it as like
it was so formative and also important
to me in my entire life
it's exactly all i know and it's it's
basically been my dad like this this
sounds weird but it's like my my dad and
i he didn't teach me a lot of man [ __ ]
so all of the man [ __ ] that i learned
came from coaches and sports like that's
it right so how to be tough how to be a
leader how to like how to not complain
how to how to communicate with with
teammates like all of that stuff
truly came from from sports and not my
father so that's why it's like i almost
talk about it like it's a family member
yeah no that makes sense yeah
but the mba i mean i probably figured
out the nba when i was
junior or senior in college like so
but this is again this is like
pre-pre-stats on the internet like they
were just kind of happening pre-mixed
tapes so why didn't i have a bit on my
special about it but it's like i didn't
know really what else was out there as
besides what i had traveled to play
and i matched up fine you know even in
juco i played against guys that were
like really good but i belonged on the
court you're like this is the whole
world of basketball exactly yeah you
know the bit is like if i scrolled
through and had i known that there were
zion williamson's in existence like a 15
year old that was windmilling from the
free throw line i would have probably
just picked up a new hobby
yeah yeah yeah
yeah that's great
yeah it's super late it's um i kind of
relate to that because i played division
three football which is basically just
like people who had a
good time playing in high school and are
just like i want to do that again for
it's still hard though what needs to be
said about that is you're right in the
sense of like the talent pool yeah but
it's like high school football is hard
yeah the workouts everything is hard
yeah d3 is like a real college program
oh yeah we have to wake up weight lift
all that stuff for sure but it was it
was grueling but
i've just found because i'd like to have
a sense of humor about things if i ever
try to talk about division three and
give it its actual respect people will
just be like shut the [ __ ] up but so
it's just easier for me to just [ __ ] on
it and and just deep down i know that
it's a real thing but just to be like
yeah [ __ ] [ __ ] playing d3 but like
i yeah i mean we won a national
championship it was it was a great oh
wow program
what position did you play receiver at
uh cool at mount union but
my whole life because i grew up in
cleveland
and my whole life
everyone in my family my dad ever went
to ohio state and the biggest ohio state
fan still now and i was just like yeah
i'll probably i'll probably win a
heisman ohio state at some point and
then
then i go obviously not good enough even
close to get recruited anywhere almost
not even good enough to even play at
where i mean at the d3 school i was
still kind of riding the bench the whole
time but
even my freshman and sophomore year i
would be like lifting extra and being
like i think i could transfer to a house
i could get some good film here i could
transfer to ohio state and then it's
like dude they're draft classes here
they had two receivers in the first like
five picks i'm like i should that was
like five years ago i was still
completely delusional i don't understand
like looking back it's like how could
you even how could you even think that i
don't it's funny though because
necessary it's it's similar to comedy
in in the sense that like
you need that delusion to survive
at first you know like at least at first
and then yeah i don't know about you and
how your coaches were but i never had
like real high level coaches like all
especially now like all the stuff that i
see is available on youtube and
tutorials and things and trainers and
this and that like i'm super jealous of
the skill set a lot of the young kids
had because there's just more
available to them i had like math
teachers that were my basketball coach
and yeah you know and like yeah my
english teacher who was also the
baseball coach wanted an extra five
grand so he also coached the basketball
team and like that's kind of changed the
trajectory of some kid's future by not
playing them because he didn't like he
for sure didn't like my game i should
have started as a sophomore and instead
i got sent down to jv after making
varsity where i averaged 27 points a
game on jv [ __ ] and it's like it's like
dude if i'm averaging 27 on jv i just
shouldn't be there i shouldn't be
playing jv it doesn't make sense and i'd
get called up to varsity practices and
do well but he just hated how i played
that's bizarre because i'm sure that
other jv coaches were like what is wrong
with this coach like what or is this kid
just having an insane game or like what
is going on yeah like that i mean it was
games but also like you know now i look
back at those seasons that were like
with my real of age friends like jv
sophomore year because i was always kind
of playing ahead a little bit right and
that was one of the most fun seasons i
played one season of football because
again
my coach i got recruited for soccer
as well growing up because i was
third leading scorer i think behind two
seniors as a as a sophomore right so the
next year basically the car keys are
handed over to me this should be my team
yeah and instead my coach was just like
an alcoholic that benched me
inexplicably never explained why i had
conversations with him he just couldn't
really
really articulate why he hated me so
he definitely changed the trajectory of
me potentially playing in college and
instead i played football as a senior
and had the time of my life with my
friends dude that's crazy because one he
was probably just like why is this kid
even i don't care about soccer why the
[ __ ] is this kid even asking me about
this this is just like a hobby like
pickup game almost and also that's so
wild to like start playing football your
friend your senior year yeah of high
school and then like
i don't know that's awesome that it was
it was such a good experience because i
feel like
hearing all that like makes me think
like things have changed a lot or maybe
i went to a good program for high
schools because dude our high school's
like
and i graduated high school in 2016 and
we did for every we had a speed and
strength class that you could take that
our coaches would make you sign up for
as a credit so eighth period every day
we'd have an hour of lifting and if you
at but your only junior or freshman and
sophomores could take that class so
after that junior and senior year if you
wanted to play football it was mandatory
6 a.m lifting before high school at the
high school four days a week practice
after that off season stuff like it was
pretty similar to my experience in
college but obviously it's very like i
feel like nowadays there's a lot of
programs are in high schools are like
we're taking this like completely
serious like we have a strength and
conditioning coach in our high school
yeah and that just is like you just have
some math teachers like i don't know
anything about soccer and i'm drunk
right now
well the coach of my of my high school
that i went to now was an assistant like
first year assistant when we started and
now he's like one of the longest tenured
coaches in school history they've won
the sections like five to ten times it's
like uncounted how many times they've
been you know states like all this [ __ ]
and he's like a real true basketball
coach so again it's like
it's just jealousy like it's pure
jealousy to be like man you guys really
have an established thing going here and
you know exactly what you're doing as
opposed to just like grabbing in the
dark [ __ ] that we did yeah literally
just like if you guys want to play like
i guess just go yeah yeah
we'll run a motion yeah
five out would you say that um
like when you're in like
people could call it the flow state when
you're up on stage like in the moment
and you're
not thinking about what you're doing
you're just loving being a comedian
versus when you were just like
out on the court just saw some people up
just not even thinking about it just
like
going off
is that similar feelings or do do you
have one preference to another of comedy
versus just hooping
that's a that's a great question it is
similar i think and this isn't to say
that uh that comedy is unsatisfying i do
think that like i've had games where i
just went off and went crazy and had
like nine ten threes and like truly
could not miss it's like that michael
jordan quote about the 92 finals when he
hit six threes in the first half and
he's like the rim just looked like a big
old bucket and i was just bucking from
everywhere and it's like sometimes you
just get into that where your your brain
almost isn't conscious
you're just kind of moving and your body
is responding to everything like bruce
lee like be water like do that [ __ ] and
that's how i look at steph curry where
i'm like this guy
operates on a different level of
consciousness sometimes when he's out on
the court like he's like [ __ ] tesla
harnessing electricity
it's crazy the way the way in which he
goes but then also
if you're in stand-up and i've had those
sets even i had i had one in tampa
where it was like i'm in this odd place
right now where i just put out an hour
so i'm scrapping that entire you know
trying to scrap the entire thing but i'm
also going into markets for the first
time so i have to put on a good [ __ ]
show so i have to use maybe some of that
and use some of the stuff from older
albums to supplement exactly the new
that i have yeah and that eight o'clock
saturday show which is typically the
hottest show of the weekend but this one
you know it could go either way but this
one was really great
my 20 new minutes turned into 35 and
it's just like one of those things where
you're i'm in and out of the crowd in
and i'm i'm changing gears without even
thinking about it you're operating
it's almost like this is how it should
be and it's like
yes sure but it's also like it's special
when that happens it's like there is
something that comedians performers or
whoever are tapping into
that things can go well without that but
when you are that when you are connected
to that when you are like it is a pure
symbiotic relationship between you and
the audience and there's just some
unspoken connection and things are just
like firing
man there is there is nothing [ __ ]
better than that yeah damn that sounds
romantic dude
that is so i i hear you know comics say
all the time like
they can tell when a show maybe doesn't
go as good even though the audience
would have no idea yeah in the reverse
of that do you think that that show
you're just describing right now do you
think that people even can pick up on
that or is that just an internal thing
because you know all what everything
that's happening
so some people do that's a great
question again it's like i i think
that show in particular this is very
funny actually so because i got nagged
so hard after destroying that show so
you know that was one of those shows
where like afterwards the lobby is a mad
house the people that are there for the
next show are like what the [ __ ] just
happened in there people are taking
pictures they're grabbed they're like
holy [ __ ] that was such a fun show like
best time ever blah blah blah
and you know so so certainly they felt
the connection it's not just the
performance there was something more
about it right and then this guy
giant giant dude uh he uh
giant black guy wearing a fedora and i
we kind of had a back and forth during
the show that went well wasn't too like
there was nothing like slant like i
didn't slam them or anything like that i
made mention of the hat i offered to
wear the hat for the rest of my set yeah
it was like you know a fun little thing
that everybody cheered and then after
the show you know people are just like
taking pictures there's so much love
there and he like kind of grabs me away
from somebody that uh that was
complimenting me and he had this huge
smile on my face and he goes to dap me
up and he goes man chappelle you are not
[Laughter]
for several reasons because one i've
never i've never compared myself to him
is my favorite
time it's like i wouldn't i wouldn't
ever do that i don't talk about the same
things frankly gender doesn't even
interest me all that much and i've never
i don't know i just i've never pretended
and it was like a smile slam yeah so he
was so warm god that's psychotic dude
so so i dapped him up and then my face
changed because i was kind of like
looking at him like
huh like why do you think that this is
okay like why do you think that this is
your job to try to take me down a peg so
like you like the fedora that much that
you guys
yeah dude he was livid about the fedora
it was a big confidence purchase and
apparently i really poked some holes in
that before he went out he was like sure
the fedora i don't know
so i but it was it's kind of
a magic moment where it's like you
realize things as you go in comedy right
so i'm 14 years in just about and
it's gotten to the point now where i'm
still i'm still an insecure mess but
there are moments where you feel like
you're breathing fire and you figured it
out you've got this whole thing locked
and this was one of those moments where
this guy just to my face told me to suck
his dick basically in other words and
he's like there and he's continuing to
put me down
like he's just like saying but again
with a smile and so i just kind of
looked at him turned my head and then
just without mention just turned my back
to him and started taking pictures yeah
with the people that are like that was
amazing like yeah like like i was locked
into this one-on-one interaction and i
was like
why am i choosing to take this abuse and
then i was like i don't even have to say
anything i could just turn and be
disrespectful because he feels
comfortable putting that [ __ ] on me yeah
so [ __ ] him and as i'm turning i could
literally hear him be like oh look at
this [ __ ] turned around now
yeah like he somehow won that
interaction
also like like him thinking that like
after your your first show at
sidesplayers you're like i am i'm
[ __ ] dave chappelle dude i am like
like
also like you're not like you said you
have completely different
i don't know that was it took him all
show to i like him sitting in the
audience being like what am i going to
say after i might smile i'll do the dap
but then i'm going to slip in this
chapel
that's that's hilarious and i love the
way that you just turn your because
that's the thought that i would have
sitting there being like you know
is this even real like i could just turn
around and like i wonder what would even
and then you just did it all
and the thing is it's not like it's not
really real like this guy is just
whatever hurt people hurt people or
whatever or he's just a lunatic it's
it's just one of those things where like
you know this is kind of of the time but
people like to debate reality right now
and like to debate what just happened
and it's like dude
say you don't like me that's fine i mean
you don't have to you don't have to say
anything you could just not like yeah
you can just leave you don't have to
stand in line to tell me that you don't
like me super bizarre
decision to do that but it's also like
you can't debate
what happened like i said things and the
response was positive right like
objectively positive there's no way to
look at it otherwise so it's it's a
weird thing to kind of come in and be
like i'm gonna poison this well a little
bit just to like kind of try to ruin
this guys yeah
it is it's and it's but it's also props
to you for just like
because isn't it crazy how like nowadays
anyone can just get in your ear about
anything like like everyone has complete
access to to you or anyone whether it be
online like
you know like people have access to klay
thompson's head like we were talking
about before like that's crazy that's
insane and so and also like it's
sometimes i think it's strange how at
these comedy clubs people might even be
surprised like how easy it is to
really just
after the show like interact with
the comedians like and you can say
whatever you want most of the time
though i feel like people are like they
code they go buy a ticket because they
want to see the show so it's like do you
have a lot of
weird interactions after shows or was
this maybe a yeah well especially now
like you know post
post during whatever phase of covid were
in um you know i'm sure anybody would
have a problem with however i'd frame
that but you know yeah uh but i'm in
tampa so it's been post the whole time
oh yeah exactly i mean dude or pre or
whatever that's i so i was there in
march of 2021 and that was like my first
big road like fly somewhere
to do stand-up since the pandemic
because in new york we were locked down
like it was a it was it was just more of
a thing
and there was zero social reluctance in
florida like nobody everybody was just
close breathing didn't give a [ __ ] and
i'm like shivering when people
approached eight feet so it was it was
it was weird but also like kind of nice
it reminded me of of how humans interact
yeah which is great but yeah i mean
since
since covid began it's it's either given
people a license
to be psychotic
or it's actually tripped people's mental
acuity to being psychotic because the
behavior that people are exhibiting now
is so
bizarre i mean socially unacceptable and
bizarre on every single level and it's
as if they just kind of took the
shackles off and we're like everybody is
gonna hold my mental illness from now on
yeah they just give you a duffel bag of
your of their issues and they're like
yeah you deal with it yeah and and and
they and they're like and i'm the normal
one too sometimes it's like oh dude i
was
i i was it's almost like everyone kind
of lost their minds and no one even
realizes it's still not at all
it seems like oh it's kind of over
or like
yeah it seems like it's over or whatever
but like people
are not the same
like it's no
like life is weird dude still people are
losing their minds and i feel like i am
too a lot of times but a lot of times i
just feel like so detached where i'm
like i don't even know like i've been in
a simulation theory i'm just like who
whatever dude like like i'm just gonna
keep doing my day-to-day my personal
[ __ ] cause like
what am i like is this real dude i don't
even yeah how else are you gonna just
navigate life besides just acceptance
and be like all right like you know
there's i can't fight this because it's
out of my control but like yeah so i you
know a big part a big part of my special
is about our living we lived at our my
in-laws my wife's parents uh for like 14
months during the pandemic like you know
we we knew it was coming we had a lease
that was up in brooklyn we were going to
extend had everything been different we
were going to live there for a long time
right but everything happened my i rely
on congregation to to make money my wife
is owns a floral company so she does big
events so she relies on congregation we
have a brand new baby and we just kind
of like hunkered down at my in-laws for
what we thought was going to be a few
weeks a month
and instead it was 14 months of of my of
my father-in-law like
perpetually radicalizing the dirty like
and and i've been around this i used to
host a conspiracy theory podcast so i
know yeah i know what this is and i know
the laughter
yeah
but it i was the only person
that he looked to and that would listen
so i was his sounding board
belligerent sounding board for 14
[ __ ] months so my entire grasp of
reality
was shaken yeah like i just i just
didn't really i mean i still kind of
don't because of all the interactions
since but not with my father-in-law but
with everybody it's like i no longer
have belief in people yeah like dude i
don't i don't know if i believe in
anything anymore
a belief in science i remember when this
first started texting my girlfriend like
this will probably take like a week
right and then you know scientists are
scientists can figure this out dude
these nerds they'll be on it all the
technology we have all these all the
brains yep apparently not i was like so
let down by the scientists i also
remember it's funnier like how short
everyone thought it was going to be we
were on spring break it was my senior
year of college we're on spring break
and we got a message that
we were going to be remote the rest of
the semester but we're all in fort
lauderdale right now being like let's
[ __ ] go we're all going back to
campus we're all remote we're it's going
to be a party the rest of the time but
no none of us saw each other ever again
we all go home
we all had to go home and like stay with
our parents and be like the spring of
our senior year just like this [ __ ]
like that was the most depressed it
sounds so stupid about a break on
tuition
um
no but we got a break on all we got past
we got the option to pass fail for that
last semester so oh i mean i guess but
it's like cool i get to pay for i was
graduating anyway yeah i was like
yeah i was gonna graduate and and it was
stupid because they only did a c minus
was a fail and i was like that's not a
fail a fail is an f
f stands for fail you can't say that we
can do
pass fail and then i get a c i earn my c
minus yeah and you're like dude i also
got to see my this is crazy
because i'm now running this channel but
the class was it was psychology of humor
and it i just wanted to do it because
someone told me that the final was that
you do stand up for the final oh cool
and it was like most your grade and i
had already been at hilarity's at this
point and like fine and i was like dude
i'm just not gonna have to do anything
the whole time then i'll just pass the
final already like no one else in this
class has a tight five already this will
be easy
and it was like and i wrote an email to
get into the class because you had to
have prereqs to get into this psychology
goal
and i was not part of psychology at all
it was like a higher level um psychology
class but i just liked the stand-up part
so i was like
hey i've you know i've been in these few
comedy competitions and i did pretty
pretty well in these rounds and sent
them some clips i was like i just want
to be part of this class like i don't
have any psychology classes yet and the
guy let me in and it was like
basically loose or base loosely based on
humor but mostly psychology oh wow and i
was like this is so hard
i was a marketing and sport business
major and i'm like dude this is [ __ ]
when do we get to do the stand-up
and we never got to do it because we all
had to go home because of code
god it was just pass fail but i got to
see my i would have failed so i had to
take a c minus for psychology of humor
jesus and and now that's
well that's similar to my college
experience because i so i i did the two
years at junior college played
basketball i got recruited to a couple
other schools i ended up choosing
geneseo uh suny geneseo which is in
upstate new york near rochester it's a
very good academic school i thought it
could like you know set me up for
whatever i wanted to do after that i it
was like between advertising and maybe
becoming a basketball coach like i was
just thinking of those things and
so
a lot of my credits didn't transfer
which is weird because it was suny to
suny and that was like the big push on
why you go to one and then do the other
and it just like would not transfer
through so i had to take a full language
course like three three of them to get
through
and get my language requirement which
was insane because i was an advertising
and journalism major yeah and so i do
that i go to like
i stayed up in campus during the winter
i did a summer course i did like my
final semester was a spring course with
like a full-on ecuadorian woman who had
no teaching experience they just like
took her like spanish
we actually staged like a a small sit-in
at my dean's office because of this
teacher because we're like we're not
major like we're not spanish majors we
have questions in english we don't know
what we're doing and she is truly
incapable of answering the questions
it's not her fault she's just incapable
right right and so they they did a pass
fail thing with us but it was stressful
i did all this stuff got on the
graduation roster didn't walk because my
parents were going through a divorce at
the time so i didn't want everybody to
show up and it'd be like a huge issue
a year late but you know graduated all
that stuff
a year later my mom gets a letter home
and this is after i think they may have
even sent the diploma or sent like you
know proof of graduation and they sent a
letter home saying i was three credits
short
and the class i was missing is public
speaking
[Laughter]
and i've since
i've since like messaged that you know i
tried at the time i was like with brand
new with comedy and i was like hey like
i'll
i'll do stand-up i'll write a thesis
i'll pay
for the for the credits like let me let
me do this and they're like no you have
to come up here for the class and i was
like [ __ ] you i will absolutely never
say a positive thing about your
institution again geneseo state
university the suny school is a dog [ __ ]
college and the people that run it are a
bunch of [ __ ] western new york milk
hicks let's go
let's go
that's hilarious it's so funny to be
like no you didn't pass public speaking
you're like i'm i'm a comedian
so when did its first start like when
did comedy first start becoming part of
your life and then when did it first
start becoming part of something that
you wanted to do with your life
so part of my life i
i always like you know this is all the
way back to like tgif like we would
watch family matters and i would
love the pratt falls i watch i was i was
weirdly even as a young kid super into
and living color like i i was always in
the living color guy over saturday night
live i loved jim carrey i love the
weigh-ins like i just thought what they
were doing was was cooler in my opinion
i just wasn't keyed into snl
and i and jim carrey's physicality all
that stuff so i was doing
those things while being an athlete like
i was always the funny guy on the team
you know i had to to ingratiate myself
and and find my social place amongst
everybody right and
and it kind of got to the point where in
seventh grade my english teacher she
gave me 20 minutes at the at every
friday at the end of the last period of
the day which was called quiet study and
she gave me 20 minutes to do stand up
like every week for a while and i was
mostly doing like
20 minutes
i know yeah i was just doing like
you know i was copying dana carvey i was
copying jim carrey like
dana carvey's first hour kind of
got me into stand up where it was like
him doing the oj stuff the music stuff
like all that i i would just i love that
hour so much that i would basically just
do that on a loop every single week
movie quotes you name it stuff like that
and i mean even as young as seven though
i watched my dad
and my grandfather died laughing at
carlin's jamming in new york
and that that like kind of
put something in my brain where i was
like oh that's how you get their
attention
you know i was like maybe i could do
something like that to and you know get
their attention more people's attention
it's all
about attention
and then when i was playing junior
college basketball i started taking
courses like i took tv production i took
radio production because it was all part
of my communications and journalism
major and that stuff
got me into potentially being a
performer we're like my you know this is
how desperate i was for a father figure
is one of my teachers was like you i was
super politically inclined at the time
he was like you remind me of jon stewart
and i was like well dad thank you very
much i'm now off on this career path and
that's basically the deciding factor of
what made me a stand-up he gave me all
these different tapes of the daily show
early daily show with jon stewart told
me to watch it study it and i did and
started writing my first bit of stand up
you know with my teammates i'd have them
check it out they thought it was funny
and uh you know from there
the interest grew and i did my first
ever open mics up in geneseo which is
kind of the only positive experience i
can glean from that yeah from those two
years and then uh
after that yeah it was kind of like a
slow little
slow start in the city because i had to
get a job i had to like find my footing
i had to move out of rockland county and
into the city and you know figured that
whole thing out so
in 08 the year after i graduated or six
months i guess that's when i really
really started to hit the ground and
just do open mics bark i barked a lot in
times square so i was handing out uh
flyers and tickets in [ __ ] subzero
degree weather i was poorly dressed like
i had converses on for no reason so my
feet were freezing it was just like yeah
but again like talk about romantic i'm
i'm so into comedy like i love it i've
read every single book there is i've i
used to play poker for a living and i've
spent thousands and thousands of dollars
on dvd's albums comedy whatever books
you name it like all of this sort of
stuff because when i become obsessed and
addicted to something it just becomes
my entire life so while i'm out there
freezing my dick off the thing that got
me through was that delusion we were
talking about a little bit of delusion
like this is the romanticization of of
the careers these guys had to do this
i'm passing out flyers eventually i'll
be able to tell this on joke world you
know like this
will be an interview piece that i'll be
able to talk to people about and it just
like
if you really convince yourself that
that's what you're doing you can kind of
get through anything yeah that's cool
did you look at back on some of the
like maybe the things that were that you
thought were so important that really
weren't that might have been kind of
[ __ ] like i remember like i remember
being like dude i gotta go get like go
to the library and get like how to write
jokes and books like that and it's like
those
maybe you disagree i feel like a lot of
that [ __ ] does absolutely nothing like
the way to do it is just to to do it to
a certain extent or maybe like nowadays
you have so much like footage of
of like
so many successful people like talking
about stories like that or like talking
about how they started and where they
are and i feel like dude just like go
listen to
some like a lot of podcasts and just
like there's so much
yeah now especially that's like info out
there i think when i started
wtf may have just started like so that
was like i was locked the [ __ ] yeah into
that show i couldn't believe that there
were comedians
talking so in depth about comedy and
yeah you know exposing what it's like
and and their their struggle with it and
stuff so i
i got super into that i'm never a booker
class guy obviously and you know
so i learned the hard way i'm that's why
it's taken me a long time to get
good in my opinion and i still think
that i have i have a lot to grow but i i
can't
take lessons from people it's like one
of my major character flaws so i had to
watch observe
take note internally and then put it
into practice by myself it's just not
something that somebody could sit me
down and tell me
so how did you get going after the
because we were talking about a little
bit before this about um because this is
something i just personally want to know
we were talking a little bit before this
about my relationship to actually doing
stand-up is like i i love it but
i
at this point in my life only getting up
like once every one or two months i
can't call myself a comedian but when i
go up there i feel like you know i do
i think i do very well
but i'm doing the same thing every time
it's not that exciting i'm not growing
when i know so much from editing clips
and
and all this stuff of people
saying what it takes to really get there
and and i know for a fact i'm not doing
that yeah but i how do you get from the
first like
i don't know how do you just get into
the rhythm of like i'm going to do this
every so to me when i'm going to do
stand up i'm gearing myself up all day
i'm writing out my my jokes i'm like all
right let's do this let's it's going to
be great and it is but then i don't know
if and then i'm like riding that high
for
10 days
and i'm just like i'm the man for like
10 days and then i start getting sad
again because i'm like i haven't gone up
in a while i'm such a frog but so like
how do you how do you write that first
time how do you just ride that out and
just be like
this is what i'm doing i'm gonna just
keep showing up
so again i'm stupid so i didn't like
i i didn't
i was i was the same as you or it took
me a while to realize that is it it is
an everyday thing like basketball like
sports like there's a work ethic to this
[ __ ] it seems so easy when you watch it
as a casual observer so you're like you
got it or you don't but the fact is i
was a i was a bad like everybody but
especially i was a bad comedian when i
started yeah i was an edge lord i was
like so into jim norton that i did like
a bad impression of him and he walks
such a fine line and is so good at what
he writes and delivers that like the
margin for error is so small i'm up
there just being like i'm exactly the
same you can't fart you know yeah like
whatever
and it just like it wouldn't microphones
like ringing and it's like a shitty
[ __ ] yeah
yeah and it would work to an extent
because again the delusion can only
carry you so far but there were like
more good sets than bad but it's one of
those things where
i don't know if i
it probably took me like five
five plus years to recognize what it
took
to do it you know or at least with me
and and even there's levels to it where
it's like okay that was my first little
bit of realization and then like at
eight i had a little bit more of a
realization and then when i quit
drinking i had
like it's just brought me to a different
level with my not only just writing and
performing but
understanding my own brain and how it
works and listening to thoughts because
that's what i was bad at man it's like
when you when you drink or when i drink
i shouldn't put this on anybody else
when i drink often times it's to mute
the voices right now you can put that on
me that's yeah yeah so it's to get it's
to get out of my [ __ ] head it's to
slow everything down
and i recognized that i was basically
silencing my writers like i was
i was drowning them in booze and once i
stopped and once i started you know it
took me a while even after stopping to
kind of shake that [ __ ] and get
fully comfortable on stage but it's like
once i stopped i recognized that these
voices were in aid like they were coming
through with things that
even stuff that i would say to my
friends that was entertaining and i
would repeat those stories as if they
were bits two buddies two different
buddies and it would work yeah and then
i'd go to stage and be like you know the
difference between dirty strip clubs and
clean strip clubs and it's like this is
not what i talk about this is yeah what
i am i'm just copying comedians and just
the idea of me doing that to my friends
and then translating that to stage only
dawned on me very late
so you know yeah it's embarrassing but
it's it's true you know
that's so hard to do though because this
is a
common theme i feel like i've talked
about
with a few guys probably because it's
something that i personally am so
curious in because like that's what i'm
kind of
like going through right now it's just
like on stage i feel like well first of
all the edgelord thing made me laugh
could say my first few times getting up
it was just like what would be the most
offensive thing i could say just in
and they weren't even really funny but i
like i was just like i don't know what
else to say it's like a guaranteed
reaction yeah so like women can't vote
and it's like that's not even a good
joke they can and it's not even a good
joke
i mean funny enough is that's like
that's circling back you know what i
mean like a lot of that stuff is is
rewarded now where it's not necessarily
like great comedy but it's saying
something that like you're not supposed
to say slightly and yeah you know that
can be used really effect
rightly but it also can come off super
well i was doing it as like i've been on
stage twice and i'm 19 i was being like
it's so embarrassing and cringy and i'm
whatever
but wait till you're in your 30s and you
you think back to that and you start
just shivering out of [ __ ]
embarrassment dude there were people
they're real people in that room like
that was not the worst thing i've seen
and also dude i also remember like every
set i was like i think that went pretty
well just because i was up there and now
i look back and i watch videos and i'm
like there were like three people
laughing and the ma oh dude i don't even
know them you if you've experienced this
but when you're watching back your old
tape and the main laughs are coming from
the person holding the camera which is
obviously your buddy and you're like oh
god i thought this was way better than
what it was
i have like i have one set
from 08 which i actually i put a clip of
it at the end of my special because it's
at the same venue that i filmed my
special so it was at triad theater i
started out i did a did a bringer like
first show in new york city i brought 65
friends and family
yeah i made i made the book or like tens
of thousands of dollars and he gifted me
with a tape that i got to pay for and so
but like
up you just cut out there
now it's back i'm back all right sorry
okay anyway let's just did that for no
reason all right
yeah
so i uh
i don't know what i was taught what was
i saying uh the booker show where you
brought like 65 people and you got oh
yeah i did i wish that there were
i wish i wish that there were like
a little bit more
footage from when i started
so because
listen was i embarrassed by it yeah but
it does like on a default level or at
least like a small like kind of like
it gauges your success where
i started this trying to be really good
at comedy that's still my main objective
is to be really really good i hope that
success kind of comes
with that right as you as you progress
and get better at your craft hopefully
success kind of comes with that but
the only way to really know
is it's like watching you know watching
my son grow
he looks the same to me but then you
look at pictures and you're like holy
[ __ ] like you're [ __ ] huge you've
been so big over the last six months and
it's similar with comedy where you're
like i don't know if i've gotten better
i think i suck i don't know what's going
on i haven't done well in a while and
then you watch an old tape and you're
like oh [ __ ] like yeah actual tangible
evidence that i've progressed
that that was a great announcement i
that i don't know because you stopped
talking but the audio i just finished
the audio and then you were smiling
while i was still finishing the audio
and that's the first time i was like i
think this might be [ __ ] up because i
was like that's so funny i'm like
nodding and you're just like not talking
[Laughter]
that's awesome dude i just like i i mean
it's so funny because you can tell how
far you've come just like
i i remember writing down in like trying
to write jokes and writing down like
parentheses long pause and i'm like god
god dude like what am i or just like
writing down like tooth and then do
something with your hands and i'm like
yeah
what is this like it should i but like
you grow in everything i guess but
trying to find your funny voice that you
are with your friends when you find out
for the first time oh i'm a pretty funny
person like
then that's just never i feel like how
people start off on stage it's always
trying to like be a comedian not be
yourself being funny which is so strange
because the only reason you have the
confidence get up there is because
you've been funny your whole life and
and everyone tells you you're funny and
your friends you crack them up all the
time so then you get up there and then
you're like i'm gonna be someone else
now now i'm gonna everyone tells me i'm
funny now i'm gonna try to be some other
person like yeah that's crazy how that
works i forget who this might be a
geraldo quote or i forget who it comes
from but they were saying that it's like
there's there's a difference between
being super funny with your friends and
then being funny on tuesday at 8 30 5
p.m yeah you know like that's true
it's hard to [ __ ] do that to be able
to turn it on and to also on some level
perform mind control on a room full oh
it is mind control
yeah
i'm gonna make you make an involuntary
noise and bodily reaction against your
will like that's magic comedy really is
is magic in a lot of ways
all right i got one last question for
you and then i'll let you get out of
here
just unplugged there we are we're back
we're back now for the for the last
question and then and then we'll let
mike cannon get out of here no you i
think that this is something that my
audience would really enjoy hearing
about and something that i
from you know cutting all these clips
would really enjoy hearing about these
these new york comedy hangs look so much
fun you guys seem so much more fun than
the l.a crowd or the austin crowd you
don't have to say anything bad about
anyone else but like how fun is it
hanging out with these new york comics
it feels like right now
the group of comedians in new york and
[ __ ] is like
it's just the best i don't know
yeah i think it's a
it's a good time it's hard it's it's
harder to hang out now because it's like
you know it's a 24 7
content production arm now everybody has
to be their own studio
and so the hangs and and community is
has fractured a bit and obviously with
all of the political [ __ ] that is
now like infiltrated stand up and you're
either on one side or the other and
if you make a certain kind of joke you
can't sit here and similar and you know
all that's it's just like
so that's the
listen wherever you go you got to find
your people right and when you find your
people it's the best and when you find
people that care about the thing that
you care about the most the same then
it's just another level so new york
comics that i've found or at least the
ones that i hang out with and respect
and love
they are obsessed with comedy as a craft
as a as a as a skill
and what they're trying to control is
their output and body of work
but you know outside of that it's like
i've i've yeah i've hung in some pretty
brutal circles in new york too where the
only conversation is algorithm and how
do you you know how do you do this and
that and it's like
you know that's what i'm trying to
escape right now is i know this [ __ ]
like yeah yeah yeah so there are there's
there's times where new york feels a bit
la ish and it's out of necessity i don't
even hold a grudge against it it's what
we've all had to do
to to create careers for ourselves based
on you know opportunity given or
whatever right so
it's just about finding your people man
like you know feeney and sagilo those
two were my best friends they're the
ones that i do the podcast with very
good buds with the stefano but again
we're both headliners and on the road so
it's hard
it's hard once you start working like
that to then come together and we have
kid you know he has kids i have a kid so
it's hard to kind of to kind of find
that time to hang but when you do it's
like
it's the [ __ ] best yeah there's
nothing better than hanging with comics
and just like you know just letting it
rip it's the greatest dude it sounds
awesome and like i saw you recently on
bar stool like those i'm such a big fan
of of that whole you know like company
in general like yeah there and they're
kind of part of the new york
comedy scene but they're not no they
aren't but they like put on so many it's
awesome like i don't even know what
you'd really call them because they're
huge in podcasting and they're always
putting on comics on their shows and all
that stuff it's like it just seems like
it's going on right now in new york well
it probably always i mean that's could
have been true for
any time in history i guess but it seems
well i'm just going to talk to you
through here now because this thing is
[ __ ] oh yeah no we're pretty much
wrapped up anyway but i was just like i
i love
it just it just seems like all the
content that i'm like wholesomely
enjoying because nowadays like editing
all the all these clips and it's like
all the podcasts that i used to really
like it just seems like i'm mostly
watching them when i'm trying to make
some sort of
video about it or something yeah it's
like especially that bar stool stuff is
is like content that i can still just
enjoy that ties in comedians and it's
just it just reminds me just like dude
this is just like a fun hang on well
those guys are they're good guys in the
sense that like they are a
self-contained organism they don't need
comedians they do not they have their
own characters that sell their [ __ ]
better than bringing in anybody from the
outside would do because it's like you
know it's like a closed comedian closed
community but the great thing about like
kevin clancy kfc uh feidelberg by all
those guys that are now platforming new
york comedians specifically yeah they
don't have to do that but it's the [ __ ]
that they are like
that's why i thanked him on my special
man it's like those guys are
are legitimately
helping the visibility of some comedians
who do not have that opportunity
elsewhere where it's like i get put on
i'm on podcasts all over the place i
haven't done tv in a little while both
both intentionally and also like not you
know like i would like of course i would
like an hour on netflix or hbo or comedy
central or wherever
the offer hasn't come through so what am
i gonna do wait no i put out my own [ __ ]
i i know how to do it at this point and
these guys at barstool who have a major
media platform are deciding that like
they respect that [ __ ] they can see it
as people who have done it themselves
they started from grassroots ground
floor [ __ ] so they're like [ __ ] it man
we'll put you on too we like what you're
doing and uh you know we'll try to
expose you to as many of our fans as
possible yeah dude they just seem like
and this is a funny i mean this word is
funny to use in this situation they just
seem like allies
they are white allies
all right well thank you so much mike
cannon this has been an absolute
pleasure hopefully we get to do it again
soon yeah i mean even if we were just
talking sports like that was just it was
it was very fun to meet you talk with
you and uh thank you for coming on the
show thanks for having me and yeah next
time i'm in tampa we'll do it in person
yeah for sure any uh socials or you got
the new special out you got yeah the new
special
special is on youtube my canon comedy
youtube.com canon comedy it's called uh
white privilege homeless i have uh two
other hours of stand up on
on the channel as well i have a crowd
work special coming out in july that i
did while on 150 milligrams of edibles
and uh we recorded it on 420 i'm
actually watching the edit now it's it's
[ __ ] awesome
so a ton of stuff coming to the youtube
that's my canon comedy and then my
podcast here's the scenario with uh
brendan sagelow and mike feeney and my
social is uh
i just give you my social security
number and my social security and my
credit
i am mike cannon and uh yeah i'm all
over the road i'll be in philly boston
uh
illinois you name it coming up so with
more [ __ ] coming in it's awesome great
to hear it go check out all of those
social links see him on the road thank
you again mike appreciate you man thank
you
[Music]
you